what i have here is a little simulation
i hacked together this morning with our
computer science scratch pad and at
first cut it's really just a way to
think about two-dimensional projectile
motion you can go left and right and
it'll change the angle at which you
launch and then you click your mouse and
it'll actually launch it'll actually
launch the object at that angle and the
velocity right now you can't set it with
the with the
just with your mouse you need to
actually go in the code to change the
velocity so right now our initial
velocity is 11 meters per second
whatever launch angle we could change it
to say 15 meters per second and now when
we launch it you see the thing going
much faster and actually much further as
well but maybe if you have a lower angle
maybe it doesn't go quite as far or you
can maybe launch it straight up
something like that as well so not all
of the variables are adjustable by the
mouse but it is it is a fun way to just
play with
it is a fun way to just play with kind
of getting an intuition for projectile
motion you see the vectors that are
being plotted around the projectile or
on the projectile the yellow vector is
the x component of velocity and we see
that's not changing and that's because
right now we haven't implemented any air
resistance
and then the orange vector the one
that's going up and down that's the y
component of velocity and you see right
when you launch it it is going very fast
in the upward direction slower in the
upper now now going downwards and there
was actually a moment there where in the
in in it switches from going up to down
and that's the point where that that
vector kind of disappears for a second
and then along with that it's showing
that the gravitational field or while
while the object is in free fall you
could view it as the acceleration due to
gravity that that is staying constant
the entire time the gravitational field
does not change while the object is in
free fall it is constantly
decelerating the y velocity even turning
it negative so that the object
eventually does come down and if all of
this is happening too fast you can
change the time increment so that's what
this dt is right over here so if every
loop you want a little less time to pass
you just lower that value so
now you'll see
it looks like it's happening in slow
motion because every time we're going to
the loop
we're incrementing time less but we at
the same total aggregate time it's just
slowing down the entire simulation and
you can even change something like a
gravity you could change it
it's like what happens if gravity is
very very low so let's launch something
and then you see in this reality gravity
and even the gravity the the
gravitational field vector you can
barely see here but the thing just keeps
floating away in a way in a way so you
could think about what might happen what
might happen on other planets so this is
this is all
this is all fun
fun and everything but
what's really interesting is that
traditionally in physics class you tend
to ignore air resistance because air
resistance complicates things a lot
especially if you're trying to work with
analytical equations but the good thing
is about computers is you can start to
model more
more sophisticated behavior and so we've
done here so these are all we've already
talked about a lot about these variables
but right here we have some variables
that could be used to model air
resistance right now in this current
implementation we are not we are not
modeling air resistance but it could be
used so later if we do model it then we
can change these variables and see what
happens over here
and so what i want you to do is to think
about how you actually can model air
resistance and we've actually
implemented an air resistance or we've
put up a shell of an air resistance
function right over here we haven't
implemented it that's for you to do and
it takes in some inputs like the
velocity in a given direction so this
could be the x velocity the x component
of velocity or the y component of
velocity the magnitude of that velocity
the x or the y directions a drag
coefficient the kind of area that's
facing into
the
that's kind of
the cross-sectional area of the object
or and you can actually define it so it
takes in other inputs there and then
earlier on we actually defined the air
density and so you could use these
variables somehow to define what the
force in that direction opposing that
velocity what the force of air
resistance would be or air friction
however you might want to view it and
then down here we just have a line that
makes sure that the direction of that
force
as as specified by its sine is opposite
the direction of what the velocity is so
if this is a positive velocity that
force is going to be negative and you
can see later in the code where we make
use of this
but the interesting thing is how do you
model this and so i encourage you to one
you could look up things like drag
coefficients and drag equations to see
what kind of people already believe or
you might not want to do that and just
try to model it completely on your own
but even if you do look at things like
drag coefficients and drag equations
there's a lot of unknowns there there's
a lot of
factors that you won't know until you
really go outside and try to model
something so the really fun part of this
is to go outside find some type of
projectile and launch it and then
collect data and then use that data to
tweak the variables for your
coefficients for whatever you put into
this error resistance so that this
simulation really is predictive of
what's happening outdoors so i really
encourage you to do that and so you
might say well you know i i might be
able to do this if i have something
where i know the launch velocity and i
know the launch angle but how do i do it
if i just have a ball and that is even
an even more interesting problem because
you actually can do a lot not even
knowing the launch velocity and launch
angle but if you just know the time in
the air and the distance that the ball
travels horizontally you might be able
to use that data to tweak your
coefficients and so a next order project
actually would even be
to write a computer program or a
function as part of this program that
can input all of the data that you
measure and then uses that to tweak your
actual variables to tweak your actual
air resistance function so that this
simulation models
models the actual whatever is going on
your object your projectile actually
traveling and then if you really want to
get into the the bowels of this code and
i encourage you to do so because this is
kind of an unfinished product here
there's a ton of improvements that you
could actually make to this code itself
one you could tweak many many more of
the variables on with the mouse you
could add some sliders or something like
that or buttons or radio buttons that
would help you
change the variables so you don't have
to keep changing it in the code you
could add more visualizations here maybe
plotting the path of the projectile
maybe plotting what it would do with air
resistance and what it would do without
air resistance you can overlay some
vectors which is the force of air
friction in in either the x or y
direction and if you really want to go
you know take it to the next level you
can even turn this into some type of a
game maybe you're shooting at some
target or the wind changes or there's
some ambient wind and you visualize that
some way so i think this could be a
pretty a pretty interesting thing to do
now with that out of the way you might
not be interested in this next part but
i will just do a quick walk through
of the code for those interested in how
this code what the different parts are
doing or might want to dig into it and
start to modify the program so we
already talked about this part these are
all just a bunch of variables that and
actually the variables up here being
used the variables down here are not
being used they in theory could be used
in when we start to think about air
resistance these are all other things
that set our initial state x is our
initial x value and i really should say
our x value initial x value in meters
in meters we convert it to pixels later
so y value in meters
in meters so the starting point the
starting point is y equals zero and then
it goes y zero meters and ends up at
zero meters again and then the x is you
see six point four two meters we later
convert that into pixels and kind of
flip the y because
the way we're doing it a high y value
the is y is essentially the height so a
high value should be high but the
coordinate system for the actual scratch
pad has y equals 0 up here and y equals
400 pixels down here so we do a little
bit of a transformation there and you
can we'll see that later in the code
this essentially sets the scale so
pixels per meter this tells us where our
actual ground is so this this this level
right over here now this breaks our
velocity into the x and y components a
little bit of trigonometry this code is
really just what selects our pictures
and actually it's a fun tweak to just
change these pictures you can actually
change what the default projectile is so
you can make purple pie be the thing
that gets projected so
let's
let's launch him so you could do all
sorts of interesting things to the code
like that and that's kind of a fairly
straightforward we already talked about
this air resistance function that would
be a really interesting thing to set
this restates the this resets things
every time you click and relaunch it
resets all of the variables
and then this right over here is
actually what draws the projectile and
all of the associated vectors with the
projectile so it gets a little involved
really just around drawing the triangles
at the end of the vector points you
might want to break it up into other
functions maybe have a draw vector
function make the code a little bit
cleaner but that's what all of that code
just does
and actually this is a little this is a
draw arrow function and then this is
this code right here is what writes all
of this information up here at the top
of the screen
and then we have the draw the canon that
literally draws this canon
and then if we go
to draw the sky in the background
hopefully self-explanatory draws the sky
in the background so if you want to
change the background you can mess with
this function and then this is kind of
the meat of the program the thing that's
called repeatedly and this is where it
collects the angle the next launch angle
based on your mouse movement so it
collects your mouse movements for the
next launch angle
and then if the mouse is pressed so
that's where you click it and it'll
relaunch it'll reset state and launch it
over again and then this draws the
background so every time it refreshes i
encourage you to see what happens if you
get rid of that line so that it redraws
everything
and then it says look if y if we're
literally at the ground or above the
ground let's increment time by a certain
amount and let's figure out what the
acceleration is in different directions
and you see over here in the y direction
we have the acceleration due to gravity
and free fall and then i put a call to
the error resistance function right now
that air resistance function just
returns zero so it doesn't affect
anything and then over here i put the
net acceleration the x direction i make
another call to the air resistance
function this time i pass the velocity
in the x direction the first time i pass
the velocity in the y direction right
now that's zero so you have no air
resistance there but then it uses that
net acceleration to figure out what the
new y velocity and what the new x
velocity is it averages them to figure
out to essentially take our our
incremental distance over that little
amount of time and this is where we
increment the distances in the x and y
directions and then we set the old
velocities essentially to be the new
ones so that next time we're through the
loop the new velocity is now what kind
of our our baseline then we draw the
projectile we draw this information and
then we draw the canon the whole reason
why i drew the canon after the
projectile so it looks like the
projectile's coming out of the canon so
that's we'll walk through the code i
hope you have some some fun with it